I've been warning you people that the
internet is killing us these days are go
to doctor is a search engine according
to science daily researchers found that
only three of the top 10 results from
symptom-based google searches were
useful for self diagnosis a researcher
told sciencedaily if you had searched
for the symptoms of something like a bad
head cold you could end up thinking you
had something far more serious like an
issue with the brain this is kind of a
problem considering google reported
about 20 of its 100 billion searches
every month was for health-related
information I love this story because I
think we all do this have you guys done
this yes you know you have anything you
have a headache if you immediately think
you have cancer or some other yeah yeah
it's not good to mean it's good to you
know just to inform yourself in general
but if you're actually on well you
should go see physician so this is one
of the catch-22 there's been a lot of
catch-22 s in the show today but like of
the internet and web technology and all
this stuff that we have access to all
this information but we don't really
know what to do it they do we absolutely
not and everyone can be a publisher
everyone is a publisher and there's so
many differing opinions so when I have a
headache I'll google it and freak out
the first time don't think oh great i
have a brain tumor and so what I'll do
then is look for another differing
opinion that tells me I don't have a
brain tumor right that's the biggest
problem because I can convince myself
that I'm not sick when maybe I am it's
causing a brain tumor exactly so much
time working out all this stuff yeah
yeah i just i think that the internet is
not yet at the point where you can make
an accurate diagnosis over it i mean
there's no question about that but i do
think the internet is amazing for the
fact that information is now free and we
can learn more about our health and our
own biology than ever before in a
previous time and so to me I think
that's amazing i regularly I'm googling
like weird health things you know which
I which I really enjoy so right so
what's the last weirdest tell thing that
you my god now you convinced yourself
you had I assume that I convince myself
ahead you know I don't I am obsessed
with brain health and nutrition stuff so
i think that like the fact that a lot of
these studies are out there is
incredible i mean before the internet
like you would either have to go to a
library but chances are libraries don't
have the most up-to-date medical
journals so to me I just I think it's
incredible the world that we know
yeah how do you guys know who to trust I
mean that's yeah I always say when it
comes to news like I don't know who to
trust anymore I feel like everyone has
some partisan agenda everybody's owned
by somebody it's extremely hard to pick
a news organization you trust so what
we're talking about health it's that
much more dangerous like yeah webmd I
mean that's pretty much I guess where
everyone goes I don't know who owns
webmd or what their connections are with
pharmaceutical industries Ron how do you
decide like what site you go to and how
do you trust that I think Google decides
because it's whatever pops I'm turns
right yeah so I don't know how scary
that is Web MD seems to be the first one
that pops up but then there's like
LIVESTRONG so you have Lance Armstrong
Foundation and we know he's totally on
the right we didn't know anything later
he's totally cool yeah I I tend to think
that the e I what I do is I look for
peer-reviewed journals I start with the
abstracts and then if you're able to
find like the full study most people to
know this but you can actually go to the
references the citation section of those
studies yeah and they just lead to a
Pandora's box of just like insight
information that you can track
infinitely down the rabbit hole and and
to me it's really really awesome but I
feel like you'd be much better in school
than I did I got pretty good I did do
pretty good but like your your [ __ ] was
much more research than my I was really
interested in science and computer
science in high school but I didn't end
up going back a Democrat I ended up
studying psychology and film the
human-machine to me as always has always
been an endless source of wonder and
fascination that's another good quote
your honor cords today so you mention
this before about the brain to
everything but have you ever convinced
yourself that you really had something
well I got back from Liberia last year I
did four trips to Liberia are working
for Riot yeah and when I came back was
freaking out they may have Ebola so it's
constantly searching symptoms of Ebola
yeah the same page over and over again
trying to reassure myself that I don't
yeah and so at least at that time it
worked for me call me down so it did cut
it did come you didn't come and did you
have any of the symptoms that could the
symptoms were sort of flu like right
there wasn't something that we wasn't
like you know people thought it was
gonna be like blood shooting out of your
eyes yeah well the problem is when
you've been somewhere where they have a
bola you get the slightest headache and
you freaked out yeah I'm a hypochondriac
anyway but you got a headache and I'm
like oh my gosh sensitive wallet it's
like first one headache did you just say
you're a hypochondriac your hypochondria
you went to Liberia absolutely well what
is that bet there's got to be some sort
of psychological condition probably go
google it all right what do you guys
think are you diagnosing yourselves with
major psychological or physiological
disease right now let us know in the
comments right